- This truly is dangerously cheesy.
- Mac and cheese inside of a Cheeto?
- Or mac and cheese flavored cheese?
- Or is it like Cheetos
sprinkled on mac and?
I don't know, it's a mixture of the two.
- I could love it, I could hate it.
I could poop uncontrollably
or I could just vomit.
- [Girl] Ooh!
- Ooh!
- The box is cute.
- [Black Shirt] Yeah.
- Who thought this would be a good idea?
- It smells like, (sniffing) vom-eet.
- [Man] Oh my goodness.
- This smells like Pringles and Cheez-Its.
- Oh God, these are good.
- It doesn't look like it
came from the Earth at all.
It looks like it came from like--
- It came from Burger King. (chuckling)
- From Burger King. (laughing)
- Okay if you're drunk you're probably
gonna want this.
- [Man] Mmm-hmm.
- Yeah, I just kinda
feel like I would order
two boxes of these and then
blame it on somebody else
like, oh I'm getting this for my boyfriend
and just go home and
eat both of the boxes.
- This tastes like box macaroni and cheese
on the inside, like Kraft.
- [Man] Yeah.
- You don't really know where the
Cheeto ends and the mac begins.
- Are you eating a third one?
- No.
Yes. (laughing)
- I say good work.
I'm not mad at these.
- My stomach is already
hurting and I've had three.
- (laughing) Why are
you eating another one?
- What would we give these out of ten?
- I would say maybe like
a, yeah, like a six.
- I would give it like a five.
If I was a little drunk,
I'd give it a seven.
- [Man] Yeah.
- It's not as nasty as
I thought it would be.
- You eat 'em once and you
should never eat them again.
(smacking)
- Finger-licking good. (laughing)
- So it's, it's half an hour later and
we really don't feel that well.
- I can't tell if it's
coming back up or going down.
- It tastes like bad decisions.